It’s Christmas day, and hundreds of indigenous Q’eqchi people
have come to the village of San Antonio Secortez
to say goodbye to
7-year-old Jakelin Caal.
Jakelin and her father left this remote
Guatemalan community on December 1st
and headed north to the United States
in search of the American Dream.
But, a week and nearly 200 miles later,
the family’s dream of a better life turned to tragedy.
Jakelin died in U.S. Border Patrol custody,
27 hours after she and her father were detained.
Her mother, Claudia, is now
living every parent’s nightmare.
For decades, Maya Q’eqchi communities
like Jakelin’s faced oppression
and systematic displacement
by U.S. - backed dictators.
African palm is spreading across the
fertile plains near the Caal’s community.
Some subsistence farmers have sold their
small parcels to the palm oil companies.
Others say they were pressured,
or even threatened, to sell.
Whatever the reason, the result
is less available land for growing corn.
Jakelin’s father, Nery, saw the plantations
as a rare opportunity to get a decent job.
He and his brother Carlos secured work
harvesting palm fruits on a local plantation.
But, they discovered that the promising job
was based on exploitation.
Jakelin’s grandfather, Domingo Caal,
has worked the land his entire life.
He grows cacao and spices, and has planted a
variety of fruit trees on the family plots of land.
But one crop is central to the lives of indigenous Guatemalans ...
and this staple is now under threat.
Farmers like Domingo say it’s impossible to
know when to plant their saved corn seeds,
as weather patterns have
become less predictable.
Drought and flooding can decimate crops,
and government assistance is non-existent.
And every year, there’s
more pressure on the land.
When farmers like Domingo manage to produce
more corn than their families consume,
they sell the excess
in local markets.
Half a year ago, a hundred pound sack
sold for roughly 16 dollars.
Now, farmers are lucky to get
just half that.
That makes purchasing beans, meat
and vegetables much more difficult.
This lack of steady jobs, combined with
smaller corn harvests and disappearing land,
means that families like Claudia’s are often faced with
the most difficult decision a parent can make.
With his options running out, Nery felt trapped …
desperate to find some way forward.
Nery wasn’t the only one from the surrounding
area looking towards the United States.
The local mayor says 200 families have left
for the border in the past two months –
some traveling with
up to five children.
Organizer Rax Kok works in local
Q’eqchi communities.
He has seen, first-hand, the impact of migration
on indigenous values and culture.
He tries to convince families like the Caals
that there are alternatives to migration.
But he says he’s fighting a losing battle,
as human smugglers take advantage
of people’s ignorance and desperation.
The Caal family won’t say how much
Nery paid for his trip,
Or whether the coyote gave him a
discount for taking Jakelin along.
But if he’s deported,
there will be large debts to pay.
Nery Caal planned to travel to
the United States alone.
But when Jakelin found out he was leaving,
she told her father she wanted to go, too.
She had a special bond with her father
and didn’t want to get left behind.
The group reaches the tiny cemetery where
Jakelin’s family built a basic tomb over the past few days.
Jakelin’s uncle, Carlos, writes
her name in the fresh concrete,
ensuring that though she might be gone,
she will never be forgotten.